wait are we rolling yeah okay so let's
get into it it's it's 9 30 in the
morning yeah it sure is 9 30 is i
believe
the time that we said we were going to
meet for this podcast this is becoming
a trend yeah now ryan was pretty adamant
about the 9 30. by the way i've been
here since 8 30. you know okay why'd you
do that well i dropped my kid off at
school
and
that was that whole thing was done by 8
15 and it's here it flew here and i was
you know i'm here it's that he goes to
school not so far from this office so
yeah so i figured i'd come in and get a
little work done and sure and get some
coffee in you get some coffee and me
yeah yeah is this are you on your first
or your second cup oh god no no i have
had a thermos coffee and then i was like
jesus
i'm gonna get some more coffee i can't
i can't do that anymore man i've cut way
back on my coffee uh yeah anyway rob's
late now before uh before we started
rolling yeah
guess what i was here and nobody told me
that the garage
i have to go to the lower garage not the
upper garage oh so it was a garage error
it was a garage here i was on time well
no see on time is uh when you don't know
which garage it is you get there a
little bit early so yeah just in case
they're going to make sure that you have
time to make the mistakes
i was told it was the upper garage and
it wasn't oh you were told it was the
other ride
so there's number garages lower garage
in the
basement are we yelling at it's already
been done
[Music]
gang goes again goes jihad
the gang goes
jihad about 15 years ago
yeah i sure did
you know one of the things i noticed in
the episode as i was watching is i was
like oh yeah yeah george bush was the
president yeah no
yes yes yes we talk about that yes we do
we've been through three
four presidents yeah four presidents oh
my god that's two we've been on for too
long guys we gotta stop i
we've been i
five presidential terms
yes because yeah barack obama of course
was elected twice two terms so
theoretically five terms could have been
fine
did we start so we started right we
started during bush's second term yes
right
and then obama won twice yeah yeah
yeah oh man wow okay all right yeah
we've been on a long time
i sure did i love this episode you did
yeah
i think it's pretty funny pretty good
right yeah i thought it was all right
yeah no it's great there's a lot of
yelling
is there a lot of yeah there's a lot of
yelling in this one yeah yeah
and i remember hearing a lot of people
say like wow that show's just just
people yelling at each other and they're
right yeah they're right i mean we were
right we were yelling funny things at
each other this in this one well yeah i
mean i think the people who like our
show like how we yell at each other it's
it's uh
it's fun i guess i was thinking about
that bit where we where we come out of
the back door and he's put a fence up
the uh josh says
who played that but it's hilarious but
um
and i was trying to remember because i
can't remember anything
now had we had we scripted that we freak
out or did we just
in the thing we're like oh there's a
fence in there that's the joke i don't
think we scripted that we that we
freaked out to the degree that we were
freaking out well yeah i mean obviously
we pushed it but like yeah but
we're always going to push that's such a
great bit that we we go out there and
there's a fence but then beyond that we
can we panic yeah we just you know we
feel claustrophobic i would like to go
back to the script because i think that
the joke was just that we walk out we
see that there's a fence blocking us in
and that's the end of the scene yeah
probably yeah there was a fence and we
were like he put up a fence he put up a
fence and it yeah
we're downtown we went through all this
work we put the fence up let's do
something let's yell let's see i'll yell
about it i mean let's scream and yell
about it yeah well i will say it is it
it was one of our things from the very
beginning of the show that we thought
could set us apart from other shows
was that it was never
my line your line your line my line my
line your line my line your line it was
always like my line oh you want to talk
and then if you because like the thing
is is like in a real conversation
the second you have the thing that you
want to say there's a very good chance
you're going to cut me off you know oh
yeah
you just did it yeah yeah yeah you guys
you got to jump in you got to get in
there yeah yeah we're always talking
about as actors like sometimes we talk
over each other each other too much and
you're like i have a funny line i'd
really like to get it out i'm looking
for a space to get it in and i can't get
it in because everyone's talking every
year you know there's another thing i
noticed that we did in that episode
which we've talked about that we did in
in the bar where we had music playing
the bar when you go into my apartment
with frank and i and we're cooking up
the the grilled charlie or whatever it
is yeah we have just like a cartoon
playing in the background you don't see
it and i like that it like creates some
atmosphere and i think it's something
we're just doing yeah it was like we we
like the idea of saying that this 30
year old man charlie kelly
uh is constantly watching cartoons in
his apartment like a little child that
scene is so funny it's so funny it is
really funny it's the idea of a grilled
charlie
it just suggests like history that you
have like a sandwich that you make it's
a ridiculous thing the way you're
dressed is funny and ann archer is so
amazing yeah she's rich she's funny in
that scene it's so funny you know i
think we've mentioned too where we just
absorbed each other's maneuverisms and
stuff i do something in that where i
have my hands kind of back on my hips
yes and i was like oh that's the posture
that you do that's a rob thing when
you're hitting on the woman at the
funeral uh in season five which i always
love i love you to do that i was like oh
that's i probably stole it from you no
no no rob you did it in the home movie
in the heart
yeah yeah that's kind of thing that's
been a thing of yours for a very long
time the hands on the hips and like
thrusting like in a very awkward sort of
stance
like an awkward power stance oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's where i move
drifting off you guys again yeah
i don't know well osmosis so funny
i thought that episode was i thought
that's that that scene in particular was
so funny i thought ann archer was
amazing i thought the slap across your
face was great yeah that was great i
remember we were trying to get her to
actually do it yeah oh to actually slap
you and she would she wasn't comfortable
with that i can't remember i don't
remember it get me once
yeah but i don't think that's the one we
used to that's not the wrong maybe it
just wasn't the best take yeah
yeah
um well something else uh that's
interesting about season two was and i
don't remember i mean when we were
writing season two somewhere along the
way we decided to serialize
the show
not that we were necessarily committing
to it being a serialized show every year
but uh we
you know the there's a there's a
continuity
yeah that episode ends sort of
open-ended mm-hmm uh which is something
that we didn't really do again until
this year we did like little bits of it
here and there but uh yeah well i think
we were what we were trying to explain
frank oh yeah becoming a part of the
game oh that's why we did it yeah that's
why we did it we wanted to slowly
integrate him into the gang and so
buying the bar yeah oh how about this do
you remember do you remember us having a
conversation the three of us as we were
writing the episode and because we would
call the the episodes the gang finds a
dead guy or the gang does this the gang
does that and then
if you recall from the the conversation
that the characters are having in the
cold open
we're referring to ourselves as the gang
and then i remember writing it and us
going
wait should we
as the characters know that we're the
gang or should it just be a show thing
so we actually write that we wrote that
in
to the scene where you're saying you're
not a part of the gang yeah and then
frank is saying
let let your sister become a part of the
gang and charlie and i are going what
are you talking about what gang
in my head so that was like a compromise
i think that we
that we made oh really yeah that we made
i prefer it i like it's a good bit yeah
it is a good bet but it's it's an
example of us very early on getting just
a little bit meta
you know what i mean but i think i think
we always had that tendency um and then
what else about this episode
well i thought the story came together
really well yeah i like that
it looked and it seemed like it was a
big effect that we did at the very end
oh wasn't though no it wasn't and like
you see so somebody like lobbing debris
at us yeah right a little bit yes but
the reverse shot of that yeah some
serious flame bars on that building
that's pretty easy nowadays we would do
that all cg because it's safer i guess
and cheaper that was real fire yeah that
was a real fire no we wouldn't do cg
fire we did real fire this year
yeah like one little flame bar but then
we'll enhance that yeah you enhance it
yeah you you double it triplet and post
or whatever but um yeah i don't know if
people know what flame bars are like
so in that scene when you see the
building on fire
uh flame bar there you go you get it
it's a bar
now guys
this is the first episode where the name
of the episode comes first we didn't do
that before before it was it's always
sunny in philadelphia would come up
right after the cold open and then we
would do the title after that
now whose idea was it to start putting
the title of the show first do you guys
remember i don't no sure don't yeah it
makes sense though because we would
often it we would often do some very
very on the nose uh ending to a cold
open and then boom
the punch line to the joke would be the
title of the episode so it made sense to
do that next but you guys don't remember
whose idea that was or how that came
about
no i just okay a bunch of a bunch of
different things
in editing
uh
i do know i do know that this is
probably the one of the first or
earliest times where we started setting
up the chara the fact that the
characters are somewhat cartoonish in so
far as
they could get hit i remember having
long conversations about this
the previous episode we got hit by a car
right or a couple of characters got like
mowed down by a car sure and then we're
like what are we gonna have them and
casts for like how how long uh from that
episode is the next episode taking place
is it a day is it a week is it a month
we got to a point where it didn't matter
anymore but now but in this episode we
had to establish frank as being a part
of the bar
so so we just had them cutting their
casts our our compromise was no they'll
be fine we'll just have them cut their
casts off in the first scene and then i
think we have frank
and that's it yeah that's all that's
mentioned but the boot is great
if we weren't establishing frank as a
character and slowly integrating him
into the bar we would have just showed
up in the next episode with nothing yeah
yeah
what are you thinking about rob your
eyes just went up to this yeah
you were looking up to the ceiling which
always tells me that you're you're
you're
you know you're thinking about it it's a
joyful memory
i was just thinking about how much fun
uh shooting that episode was i remember
being outside
we didn't do a lot of night work in
season one did we i can't even remember
but uh i remember like feeling like we
were finding our stride and it wasn't as
much like fighting i remember the first
season not fighting but like we were
creatively collaborating and trying to
find the show so the first season was
really
tough and i feel like the second season
was got a lot easier and so like at
night
when we were outside shooting that scene
where we're throwing the toilet paper i
just remember that being really fun
yeah it was really fun it was also it's
it's also yeah it was like
i during the those during those days i
don't know if we don't think we did it
that night or maybe we did i don't know
we used to
we used to you know start nipping at
some alcohol yeah
it's a lot of fun if you're not going if
you're not seeing the sunrise it starts
getting unfilled once you get past
midnight but if you know once it gets
dark it's like uh
especially if you're in your
mid to late 20s have you guys ever um
toilet papered
somebody like their house yeah or how or
been toilet papered yes trees for sure i
mean i don't know about houses yeah it's
tough to get it over a house the day
before halloween used to be like uh go
destroy your neighborhood day
the kids are gonna get some candy but
before that happens let's destroy our
neighborhood let's make them feel as
though society is holding on by a
tenuous thread here we used to do a fun
trick where we pull stop signs out oh
good
that's good right that is good yeah that
was a good trick fun trick
uh
boy
i know just the kind of thing i think
about now i'm like what in the hell i
can remember one specific halloween
where there was word that one of the
kids in the neighborhood was going
around with bags of [ __ ] and throwing
them at you
so we were out causing trouble but being
like man i hope i don't run into that
dude
the bag's a [ __ ] guy yeah and and
throwing bags of poop comes back and
then yeah in this episode we used to
also do this this thing where we would
uh we would drive by a mailbox and
somebody would hang out the passenger
side with a baseball bat and just smash
mailboxes what if anyone's ever like
yeah no he's taking that swing and then
their arms just flew off like the
mailbox right like
the mailbox won yeah like some guy's
like guess what [ __ ] i'm gonna
reinforce this mailbox you know yeah
you're right right yeah i'm sure it's
like takes the kids some type of
explosive in there so they're gonna
we accidentally uh me and some friends
uh decided to uh light a fire in
somebody's front lawn
and uh ended up lighting their entire
front alabama well
yeah no no no hang on a second there was
nothing like that it was we were you
what were you just what were
yeah oh that's what you guys were
thinking oh that's interesting that's an
interesting stereotype you guys want to
talk about um how
uh you're stereotyping alabama you guys
want to talk about that for the our fans
in alabama you were telling the story
about how you were burning things on
people's lawns
i said burning their lawn i said burning
their lawn
hey man i just burned their lawn okay
yeah
yeah there's a white at white people's
house by the way
okay in case you're
[Music]
i wondering a question for you
by this point were we still shoot we
were still shooting in the barclay hotel
right yeah charlie's i think so yeah
yeah yeah absolutely so have we talked
about the parkway hotel no okay so the
barclay hotel is this is this downtown
hotel which probably when it was built
in 1925 was the cat's meow right like
that's the place where everybody wanted
to stay the movie stars and whatnot this
is where all the i'm irritated by the
fact that you said they catch me out i
like it it just i like all the
wanted to get down at the at the barclay
hotel yeah and then sometime probably in
the in their zoo mid 60s to 70s
that turned into a well you can live
here if you want i'm i'm guessing it was
around that era i actually believe it
was charlie parker famous jazz
saxophonist i i think that was his spot
that was really that was where he yeah
he would stay there when he was in town
oh now he was also famous for
music and
i don't think i was doing obsessive
excessive amounts of drugs right i don't
know about that
i don't know that about maybe that's why
i'm stereotyping you could be
stereotyping again
now
who's the guy that ethan hawk played in
that movie miles davis
come on man
he was into the heroine for sure was it
miles miles big time okay well anyway um
the barclay hotel uh eventually became
the kind of place where you could live
and or just by a few nights or by a few
hours right i believe it still exists uh
down there it's the kind of place is
that where they found a body in the
water well in the
water
but
yeah excuse me they found a body in a
sea water oh you don't know about it
in the drinking water oh this is spooky
[ __ ] so they have like
images of this woman going up to the
seventh floor and she's acting very
strange down to the first up to the
seventh down in the first and then and
then that night they find her body in
the drinking water well no sorry it's so
much more sensitive oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's working people are
one it starts before that where people
are like
why is this water taste weird oh
god they were drinking it smells bad and
it tastes weird and it's like a
different color yeah and then they went
up and then when you say the drinking
water you're implying that that was not
also the shower water yes all of that
water yeah all of the same water any tap
water in one of these seedy hotels okay
yeah already it's suspect yeah that's
right and they went up there and they
found a body in there that had been
decomposing for a woman
up and down was she going up and down
and so so much that somebody got
irritated and and killed her and put her
in the water tank
she's up she's down she's up and she's
driving me crazy and then somebody just
like murdered her and was like i'm
putting her in the water basically and i
think you just made yourself suspect
well i'm i'm just saying it but it would
anger me as well yeah in 1930 it was a
suggestion that it was she was mentally
ill and that maybe she committed suicide
it's very it's all very
how do you get into a [ __ ] water tank
yeah i don't that's the thing well no
about how like if i want if i was like
you know what i'm going to hop into my
water tank at my house how would i do
that no you don't have one that you
could at the season no one of those big
ones on the roof that like that looks
like
yeah yeah it's on the roof of the thing
it looks like a little house
yeah yeah yeah oh okay it's great for
stash in a body that you want people to
then later drink
um
that is the thing there was a guy who's
like i want people to drink her
like you know what i mean like i don't
want to just kill her i want people to
drink her
it was like yeah it was that person oh
anyways
there had to be like a really ghoulish
guy there you were just like i know it
was him i just can't prove it look at
him look at him he wants me to drink
people i can you can see it in his eyes
i can see it in his eyes he wants me to
drink people just saying drink some
people all right but anyway the cecil
hotel and the barclay hotel are very
similar yeah very similar like if you
found out that you were drinking people
at the barclay hotel would you be
surprised no not in the slightest bit
not in the slightest and that is where
we found charlie's apartment yeah yeah
make perfect sense for them and we
essentially yes we brought in at the
time we brought in um
furniture and things like that and set
design but i don't think we changed
anything else we didn't change the
molding the floor the rubber yeah were
the walls maybe even painted that color
yes i think oh yeah absolutely yeah
because we didn't have enough money to
go strange blue wow so that room still
exists i wonder if it looks the same
because we started building the set a
few years after it's probably like
people are paying like
two thousand dollars a night to stay
there
downtown is so different now it's crazy
oh right yeah yeah yeah not like that
not that street not that area yeah
that's still time i think that's still
dan addius directed all 10 episodes of
this season uh wonderful director mostly
known for drama almost exclusively known
for drama which we uh preferred because
we didn't like it when directors tried
to make things funny we found it made it
less funny so we just wanted somebody
who could shoot a story really really
well and dan addison was extremely
talented and we needed somebody who
could pull off essentially shooting all
10 scripts as if it was one big script
because we only had danny devito for 20
days yep and then it ended up being what
25 days no i think he gave us
way more 30. i think yeah i think i
think after the first three days he was
like oh these guys are fun and this is
yeah yeah because originally i think he
gave us he was like you got me for 20
days and we're like holy [ __ ] we had to
shoot all of this originally it was 15
days it was 15th 15 days yeah okay yeah
we had to so we had to front load all
the danny scenes we shot uh pretty much
first with a couple of exceptions i
think we threw in some things for
locations and stuff like that because do
you guys remember do you remember the
first scene we shot of the whole season
season two season two sorry yes
no no
if i am not mistaken it was the scene uh
that we have that uh where we're sitting
in front of the lawyer uh played by ravi
patel
oh yeah
yeah that could be right i believe that
was the very first scene we shot of the
season and one of the things i know this
is just pure it's pure vanity i decided
to get a haircut before uh we shot that
season and my
guy just cut my hair way too short and i
hated it so much
and i remember that you're locked in
yeah i'm locked in and i just remember
that being the very first scene and
trying to figure out how to make my hair
bigger
your hair was small i was wondering what
you were wearing i noticed that i was
like i had a bracelet on that scene did
you have a bracelet yeah yeah just like
a little like a like black string
this was the first time i noticed uh and
i don't know if i did this in the first
episode of season two but certainly in
the second episode i did notice this
that i had on blue
um dickies and black boots which i then
proceeded to wear and continue to wear
uh for the next
15 seasons 14 seasons yeah so i'm going
to try to keep you like i'm probably
going to keep my army jacket and and uh
and sneakers that i've worn
through the whole thing we need to keep
them
they were mine when we started the show
and then oh my god we finished yeah
right yeah
well dickies i i just actually i brought
a few pairs of dickies back in today to
give back to wardrobe because i don't
think i'll be wearing those
consistently but i mean maybe one day
they'll go up in the smithsonian what do
you think glenn
oh there's no doubt about it yeah
everything about this show has been
celebrated widely by
great institutions such as
smithsonian so um that would be
consistent with that yeah i think so
absolutely i think that's gonna happen
um let's talk about my buddy ravi patel
yeah quite good i quite enjoyed him in
that scene he's great in the scene he's
great i love that guy uh he and i did a
short film together
after season one of the show and that's
how i got to know ravi
and uh then we cast him on the show
because he's great um and ravi and i are
still very good friends uh i love that
guy i miss him he moved to nashville
um he's still in the biz he just decided
to get the hell out of los angeles and
move to move his family to nashville so
i'm kind of missing that guy but uh yeah
revvy was great in that and uh he also
has i'm gonna do a plug i'm gonna do a
plug for his hbo show he did a show they
only did four episodes uh really quick
are they paying me anything no okay uh
so rob yeah um i'm gonna do a plug for a
rubbing show i'm gonna do a plug for
robbie's truck sorry i'm not getting
anything out of it yeah that's okay you
don't have to okay it's called
hotel is the pursuit of happiness
and it's great it's for ravi ravi's
person
what is it called i believe i believe
his name is pronounced ravi no no no no
the show
ravi potato
pursuit of happiness
okay idiot this is just like the show
where we talk over each other yeah yeah
yeah
yeah um
i remember getting in an argument with
mr dan addius about that ann archer
scene where she comes in do you recall
this
what were you arguing about well you
know the director traditionally
directs the episode and then gets his
cut of the episode and then and then the
writers and producers come in and post
and we had quite an argument do you
remember that about that specific scene
where he was editing yes yes where we we
had cut it significantly down
uh because we felt it just worked best
in the form that you see it today right
but uh
and dan have felt as though we had
really
like butchered the scene butchered the
scene uh-huh
and voiced it which is and voiced it
which is right but then
then we were like great thank you very
much and we're going to air it like this
and then he pushed back yeah so and he
pushed back on that for the folks at
home uh that maybe don't know this um
you know in in films uh the director has
uh you know much more the final agency
except for well
he's got final cut some [ __ ] some
directors get final cut but usually
there's big there's a big p producer
that comes in and he gets final cut or
she no usually it's in the studio or
or you know not yeah like it's uh you
know it's walt disney or whatever it is
right they get the final cut but uh but
the directors is the big man on campus
or woman or they or them
oh my god on a film jesus christ
uh human the big human on campus
they may not identify as humans it's the
big entity
i maybe this is a boring part of the
podcast or maybe this is something
people find interesting but
even though it seems like it's a lot of
fun to make the show and it is
and it seems like we're laughing and
having a good time all the time we're
constantly fighting with each other like
constantly but but i use the word
fighting i mean disagreeing with each
other we're not once we realize that our
egos are getting involved which they
have which they do from time to time
then we have to check that but it is a
constant negotiation yeah it's
negotiating with each other it's i
wouldn't say that it's fighting because
that that
that implies that we're just having
major disagreements of personality
and that's never happening that's maybe
if it's happening once a season we're
having a sit down the three of us sit
down and say hey i have an issue with
this that or the other thing
and
it usually happens in the writing
process and it usually
you know gets settled in an hour
discussion and then we move on but on
set it's it's all
a creative discussion you know totally
not nobody's ever yelling at each other
but i guess the point is that we're
always
navigating strong opinions and and we're
constantly compromising and working with
with one another because we respect each
other but that doesn't mean we roll over
right so everybody feels strongly about
but to your point that you just you were
just saying charlie there's usually at
least one big blow up every year that we
have to like
like go our separate ways and then for a
day or so and then come back and then
have a conversation or like i gotta
shoot you guys like a texan big i'm
sorry you're [ __ ] up you know like but
like but this year i don't think we had
that no not yet no we did we did
we did we did we were
it was something early in the writing
where
we
sat down and we hatched out it was sort
of the same frustration we usually get
in the writing campaign we were saying
we should do this on the podcast what
was that
it was
it was
the gist of it was you were getting
frustrated
rob yeah you you rob we're getting
frustrated about checks
yeah that tracks definitely because you
you had a story thing you liked
and glenn and i were oh i know what it
was
go ahead oh sorry did you i didn't want
to interrupt my mom
he just cut you off no he said
dude did you see that just cut you down
and you just jumped right on top
of him don't deflect doesn't he always
do no but it was it was that we couldn't
get we couldn't get
you wanted to just get something done it
was frustrating for you to sort of have
to slow down because we were like no
this isn't good enough and and it was
exhausting because you were like in my
mind i know it works i remember what it
was
i did too it was in the cast the castle
yes yeah okay so we had a we have a
sequence in a castle uh give it away
okay yeah don't give it away well well
okay all right
we have a sequence in a castle that that
turns bad
and uh rob had a very specific idea of
how that should be executed and to be
fair to him that was the ex that was the
idea that we i think had in the break
right so that was in the break that was
in the story break
uh that came out of the writer's room
and the outline and all that and um
it was executed that way
and when charlie and i read it we just
were like
it's it felt uh to uh it felt to us as
though it was derivative right or
something we'd done it was something
that we'd seen before or something we'd
done before in our in our minds and in
your minds it was like no this is
different enough or it's different maybe
totally you can you can attest to your
own point of view on this but you were
like i know this works why are we
creating extra work for ourselves why
are we fixing something that i know
works no but the argument came out of
you wanting to say all right fine then
you guys just do it i don't and we and
us saying no no no
i know it's exhausting but we don't want
you to just say
all right [ __ ] it you guys do it right
we want to have the argument because we
know we'll get to the best place
and
the the justifiable frustration of 15
years of that
you know of that is exhausting but
that's sort of a recurring theme which
is that
to pull to pull this off the way that we
do it's an it's an exhausting process
yeah there's a lot of push and pull and
we're constantly trying to figure out
how to streamline and take that stuff
out so to make the process easier so
that we can have
so theoretically so that we can have
more fun
um and we don't always totally disagree
on
where that line is like i i would say
that rob you tend towards
let's just make things easier for
ourselves not that you're not concerned
about quality you are but one thing
you've brought up before is that
sometimes those big blowout arguments or
those big fights those things that that
like take a lot of energy and time to
discuss well maybe when all is said and
done make the show one percent two
percent better and in your mind you're
like that's not worth it because i've
got i've got a life and i've got sanity
and and i'm i'm 44 and i've got my blood
pressure to worry about
you know like you know and and that's
and that's fair and sometimes and i tend
to come down on the side of uh
you know i'm i i'm i'm ha i would rather
have those arguments and potentially
make the show ten percent better
and then maybe be okay with it if it
only makes it two percent yeah where
where we're always negotiating or where
i'm negotiating it in my mind is when i
feel like we're making it one to two
percent different
yes that is because better is in the eye
of the
subjective
holder yes well better is in the eye of
the two against one of the two against
one that's what we've always agreed to
so we've always agreed to and it is a
fantastic process creatively and i will
say on things where i've not had it i've
sorely missed it but yeah that other
than that i don't think we had any i
feel like that argument was we're also
so used to it now that we probably don't
even notice it when we as many times as
we have those things that was the shape
of argument that we had for like three
four years but
i don't remember older ones what they
were about do you guys
oh god
older argument like big like arguments
about stuff yeah i don't really remember
any of them really
i don't feel like we had that many of
them we did really yeah oh we've had so
many so many so many what about they
were less of they were
we we weren't as capable of
communicating it i think so we would
just get pissed off and
walk away but i can't when we were
younger and more insecure and maybe felt
that we had something to prove to the
other person if they felt like you know
there was a it was almost like i mean
almost like a
this person thinks he's smarter than me
you know what i mean and i have to prove
that i'm just as smart and creative as
as the other person you know what i mean
almost like there was this the thing of
like
not competitive but
you know when you dig your heels in on
something because you you feel like it
it's it's when your ego slips into it
and we've gotten much better about
recognizing when i'm fighting for
something that i want because my ego
can't let it go versus
i really genuinely think that creatively
this is the best decision we've gotten a
lot better at at figuring out when it's
our egos instead of the
when it when it's not a creative
discussion anymore it's it's just a
digging my heels in because my ego is
hurt
um and that that's something honestly
that's something that i think that has
served me in my real life too
um through doing that so many times and
putting myself putting our being in
uncomfortable arguments with people that
i don't because i don't like
confrontation
um
but getting comfortable with being in
those confrontations um has made me able
to face that kind of stuff in my
personal relationships too
it's been therapeutic for me i don't
feel i i don't recall
ever feeling like that from either you
guys and always feeling like it was
about a sense of what is the best
version of this tv show
and digging in on that but never ever
really feeling like
it was like an ego thing but always like
strong opinions about like well what's
going to make this work or not work
which i think is great yeah well
you know different strokes for different
different interpretations for different
i'll have to go through and make a list
of all the things that we've used to
fight about i mean
different interpretations for different
beings
um
you know it doesn't have the same ring
to it does it what does something have
to be
um
right that's that's uh that's uh can you
guy i can't i truly can't remember what
any of the arguments are about can you
actually remember those i mean i
remember this season because it was only
a couple months ago it's usually about
you not being able to remember stuff
[Music]
well okay let's how about this let's
talk about let's talk about um this is
the first time we ever sang uh a song oh
yeah we came up with the idea of like we
thought it was very funny the idea of uh
that wasn't scripted right that was us
like sitting there at the end of the
description
we're just sitting here at the bar
waiting for frank to come in we should
do something yes
and the thought was what's the most
nonchalant
follow-up to having blown up a building
next door that's a good bit and possibly
being you know because
you expect it to come into the next
scene and be like what are we going to
do guys we got to make sure that we
don't there's no fingerprints we got to
make sure you know like how do we cover
our asses here we're going to we're
going to be in big trouble but no we're
we're in the bar
working out the harmonies to the extreme
song more than words yeah
and i i thought that was very funny
because i'd forgotten it watching it and
uh yeah me too yeah totally forgotten
sounded pretty good too yeah we did
sound pretty good
episode if if i'm thinking about the
first episode uh where of season one
where my thought after watching it was
hmm i wonder why people
liked the show or started to watch this
show i watched this episode and i was
like i wonder why more people didn't
love this show
why weren't people watching this show
because it's good
i think
i i do said no i've always said this i
really do think that the look of the
show is a bit of a turn off yeah yeah
the name the title the title the title
but also like i i think our sense of
humor is very specific and sometimes it
takes people a second to go oh okay like
i still think there are some people who
just don't get that the joke what the
joke is like i mean right i've often
talked about how
um i had to watch um
the kids in the hall three or four times
before i before i it finally i was so i
would watch that show and i'd be like
this is so stupid this is so [ __ ]
dumb i don't get it
you know even as a kid i was like so
juvenile and dumb like the jokes are
just dumb
and then like the fourth or fifth time
something clicked i don't remember what
sketch i was watching
something clicked where i was like oh
it's dumb on purpose they're they're
smart
making a show about they're making a
show doing sketches about dumb people
and then it became funny to me
a lot of my favorite
things to watch
you know movies whatever are things that
get better
much significantly better on your second
or third watch right people often that
was why the big lebowski wasn't a big
hit right off the bat that's a great
example to see that movie like two or
three times you watch it the more you
get out of it yeah
and what a you know what a terrible
business model that is like make
something that you're like well the next
time you watch this is going to be
better but you know lots of very popular
movies i could never sit through again
well also but
all the great ones in my opinion like on
your first viewing you're like huh but
then you watch it again it's not like
anyone i don't think anyone consciously
goes nobody's going to get this the
first time around but no second time i
mean nobody consciously no you're just
layering things in that are subtle and
then right and and hopefully doing
something different i mean i think at
any time by the way a lot of people
probably watch those movies and totally
get them the first time yeah
it's probably just a statement but it's
i find it to be the same thing with
music too where um i'll listen to an
album from a band that i like and
you know there's there'll be like one or
two songs on there i'm like i'm just not
into that song but i force myself to
keep listening to it as i listen to the
whole album through from beginning to
end and oftentimes those songs that that
were not very good to me at first become
my favorite songs and the ones that i
listen to the most
because they i don't i don't know what
that is it's like when something's
really catchy right off at the offset
it's like it gets old faster you know
but when something takes a little bit
more like time and work to kind of
sort of like
suss out what makes it special sometimes
sometimes that has more staying power i
don't know
in my in my experience and you i i also
find if you use music as an example like
whenever you talk to those like
musicians whether they're
like kings of leon like huge ma or
imagine dragons and i'll ask them like
when like they're writing in the music
they don't think of themselves as big
pop stars or big rock stars nor do they
think of themselves as like niche
they're just like i'm making what i make
i don't know what it just seems to like
and i feel like that's i feel like
i don't think of ourselves as niche even
though we are i'm just writing what i
think is funny so i think everybody is
going to think it's funny but they don't
some truth to that in terms of you're
making something that plays by its own
set of rules and those rules are
completely intangible and you're looking
at it and you're either saying ah this
isn't following the rules or this isn't
adding up to
you know what it's supposed to add up to
but there's no like pie chart of like
this is what an episode is this is what
a story is it's just something like
you've internalized i guess from
watching other things
and it either feels like the thing or it
doesn't and when it doesn't
you can't really point a finger at
anyone or anything you're just killing
yourself you're like why doesn't this
compute i mean it's this is why i i i i
i'm a bit like i'm i'm always
i i overuse the word authentic
because it's it really is true for me
that um i don't like it when i feel like
a musician
or show or a movie
is doing it for me
i want the musician
or the
the band or the the show
i want it to be that they are doing
something that they love
and they almost don't give a [ __ ] if
anybody else likes it i want to feel
like they could care [ __ ] less if i
like there's a weird middle ground in
there where it's like you can you truly
can make a movie or an album for no one
and then you'll listen to it and you'll
be like right this is for nowhere well
no i'm not sure no no no no but i'm
that's that's yes and and and that does
exist i mean you know uh certainly where
somebody makes something that's purely
for themselves and it's absolute trash
because it literally is only something
that person could enjoy yeah but but but
i think what i'm what i'm referring to
is when you feel like a band
they just write the best that's the
coolest [ __ ] that they can come up with
that that really means something to them
and is like [ __ ] awesome for them
and you know then can't understand why
nobody else likes it and then there's a
few niche people who do or in the
example of imagine dragons or kings of
leon where they're just writing so
they're like i don't know this is like
this we think this [ __ ] kicks ass
and then and they put it out into the
world and
the world agrees they're like this does
kick ass this is great and that's where
you know you you get extraordinarily
lucky because you've done something
authentic to yourself and then it's uh
it's ironically something that makes you
uh very successful
and i mean in our case we made a show we
were always making a show that i was
just trying to do something that i
thought was funny that i thought was
funny that and that i thought and i
enjoyed making you guys laugh and that's
all and i was like i'm gonna let that
just be the barometer right if it's
making us laugh [ __ ] it that's what
we'll do you know what i mean and we did
that from the beginning and i think most
of it was because we were
at least for me i was fairly convinced
that that uh it probably wasn't going to
catch on and then it wasn't going to
work so i was like so i want to go out
doing something that i'm proud of
and then it did work sort of
sort of
sort of worked yeah
well guys this has been fun
it's been fun but it hasn't been funny
um maybe it doesn't always need to be
funny were you laughing i was laughing
earlier here's what we're gonna do now
now we're gonna go and we're gonna sit
and we're gonna look at an
episode and we're gonna sit the three of
us and we're gonna look at an episode
when you say look in an episode you
we're gonna edit we're gonna edit we're
gonna get in the editing room this is
our first day in the editing room of
season 15. yep
um
we've watched a little bit we've already
given charlie and i have given
notes on a few cuts yeah they didn't ask
me they didn't ask me to come no it's
always good to have fresh eyes yeah
always good to keep fresh eyes yeah okay
sure
we're gonna let's go with that
we can maybe even
lock one today we'll see i don't know
maybe you know i don't want to put any
pressure on put one to bed here
you know
well we just put everybody else to bed
so when we put one of
all
these
[Music]